he's one of the the great Houston Oilers
of all time the 44th overall pick in the
1982 draft and of course a legend at
West Virginia he is the XFL commissioner
Oliver Luck who joins us on the program
good morning Commissioner Dan how are
you I'm doing great if you could pick
out one moment of your professional
playing career what would it be
my best moment came early in my career
was my first NFL start for the Oilers
and we were it was 1983 it was right
after that eighty two strikes shortened
year we played the Detroit Lions led by
Eric Hipple and Billy Sims and we broke
a relatively long losing streak because
my first start in first win for the
Oilers that season so that sticks out
downhill from there how long did you
last in the NFL I spent five seasons
okay I probably could have played a six
or a seven I was backing up Warren Moon
and I could have played a six or a
seventh but I had gone I was going to
law school in the offseason and I
realized that my calling was was going
to be not on the field but you know
outside of the field and here you are is
the XFL Commissioner I think by all
accounts is successful debut for the
league what is the goal as the
Commissioner of the XFL for this league
our goal really is pretty simple we want
to stay in the spring offer high quality
up-tempo football in the spring you know
sort of let folks get to know us and
understand us build our own brand build
our own sort of standalone sustainable
teams and just offer good football
minutes it's not that complicated
obviously football is America's most
popular sport but of course the spring
is the season and traditionally in which
there hasn't been much live football so
that's really our goal a relatively
straightforward play good football in
the spring how important is a
partnership with the NFL well you know
we don't have a formal relationship with
the NFL but as you can imagine we've got
well not necessarily I mean we've got
all the respect in the world for the NFL
and we've got a million touch points
with the NFL but I'm not sure that that
that's an end game for Vince McMahon our
owner I I his instructions his guidance
to me is hey Oliver build a sustainable
standalone league with our own brands
and and you know will respect the NFL
the NFL determines a lot of the things
about the ecosystem of professional
football so we have to live within that
ecosystem but and we want to have
obviously positive relationships which
we do but I'm not sure there's that
that's part of the end game necessarily
what about going after college talent
like the USFL did so you know we're not
subject to the NFL's
requirement of three years out of high
school that's baked in the CBA we're not
a party to that we do have the ability
to you know go and sign a college
freshman or a sophomore there's only one
player right now in our league a guy
named Kenny Robinson who ironically went
to my alma mater West Virginia
he's got college or had college
eligibility remaining he only played two
years of college ball and decided that
he wanted to play in our league he's
basically damned using this season he's
playing for Jonathan Hazen in st. Louis
he is using this season as a personal
combine right instead of going to the
combine and doing the drills he said I
need to play I need to get more tape I
need to you know play 10 games or 11
games against good competition and he's
doing very well a lot of scouts
anticipate him being a first second
round draft choice so we haven't really
dipped our toe into that particular pond
but we certainly could in the future
yeah that's what I'm wondering I know
Trevor Lawrence is out of your price
range but let's say you had a quart of
orange Trevor Lawrence out of your price
range I'm not sure I know what his price
range is okay but but let's say a
freshman quarterback plays well and
doesn't want to you know he's got to
stay for two more years it can you see
that that would be sort of the gateway
that's open here where somebody could
say instead of playing in college I can
go and make this my own combine or I can
go in and get paid by the XFL a year or
two years earlier that that's a distinct
possibility you know this but
10,000 Division one college football
players and there are lots of you know
challenges that those young men are
facing so I could see where guy plays a
year or maybe even you know two years
and says I need to make some money I've
got to support a family or you know
because you know illness and the family
or whatever or you know academically I'm
not interested in college there's so
many different stories the key thing for
us is this year we said to ourselves
let's get the best you know 450 or so
players we possibly can and the typical
background of that player is three or
four years of college football two or
three four years of NFL football man we
got former first-round draft choice is
playing in the XFL so you know we have
to make sure that a younger guy would be
physically emotionally mentally mature
enough to compete the beauty of getting
guys that are 3 4 years you know in
terms of the NFL the beauty is they're
professionals they know how to act and
know how to respond they they bring a
certain professionalism to the job and
that's you know we have to make sure a
college kid would be you know in that
same category he's the Commissioner of
the XFL he's Oliver Luck fans can
download play XFL app and by picking the
games currently this week and you do
that correctly you can win up to
$500,000 it's available in both the App
Store and Google Play I'm officially a
la Wildcat lifelong la wildcat fan my
favorite moment this past weekend I was
in DC for the DC defenders Seattle
Dragons game Cardale Jones threw a
couple of knights balls early in the
first quarter you know and the almost
20,000 fans there broke out in an MVP
chain optimization do and so that's been
a really fun part to watch as the fans
begin to fill these brands with energy
and their own little stories what's your
son think of the XFL he's been pretty
upbeat he's been a little bit of a
sounding board for me as you suspect he
knows virtually all the players
in the league so he's given me some tips
about certainly about some of the
quarterbacks that we went out and signed
he's friendly with guys like Landry
Jones and Josh Johnson and you know I
don't know if he knows Cardell but the
Phillip Walker PJ Walker down in Houston
plant very well he was on the Colts
practice squad for a couple years so
he's given me some good advice is Andrew
needed John no he doesn't thank you for
asking he's mr. mom right now they he
and his wife had their first child about
three months ago so he's doing a lot of
baby sitting he disappeared
how surprising it I mean I know he's
different Oliver but like maybe it
doesn't surprise you I think people kept
saying oh he's got to come back and I go
why would he come back to the sport that
put him in this mindset of I'm gonna
walk away from this and there's
something else to life than football
the media and fans wanted him back I
mean he had he had the smart assessment
in my opinion but he just disappeared
that's remarkable for an athlete yeah I
mean he's one of these Millennials that
isn't involved with social media you
know and I guess they're still a handful
of those guys out there and and you know
as a result it was really very easy for
him to you know just to get out of the
spotlight and live his own life you know
I really admired Dan anybody who's
played in the league who leaves on his
own terms right so watching Luke Kuechly
for example right in a great career
great player and I just I love it when a
guy says I'm in control I'm gonna walk
away when I want to walk away I'm not
going to let the game determine when my
career is over at guys like me we're
told when we were done but you know I
really admired that because that's
that's taking control and it's also
taking control of your post playing
future which is critical for a lot of
guys and they finally got an offensive
line for him that was my problem I kept
railing on the Colts going you're gonna
get this guy killed then you get a good
offensive line a good team and then all
of a sudden it's really the accumulation
I think of all those years where Andrew
probably just said I I don't want to do
this if I can't be great be healthy I'm
not gonna do it and walk away
do you get that you know he he did sort
of lament
to me that you know the Colts had such a
good offense
you know as he was working through his
own issues Chris Ballard has done an
excellent job that that is my you know
GM of the year it's a small market and
you know they ended up kind of losing
some gas towards the end of the season
this year but I think the world of Chris
pallet is he's one of the best what is
the new rule that you think the NFL is
gonna go I think we like that or the you
know the element that the NFL will
sample here so the one I think that that
makes the most sense I have no idea what
the NFL would do but the one that makes
the most sense because the underlying
rationale is solid is our kickoff right
so you know we tried to create a kickoff
that gives us two things one more
kickoff returns that's what fans want to
see right they don't want to see the guy
kicking the ball out of the end zone
that's not a great football play they
want to see a return and the second
reason is safety
you know player safety that matters in
today's world so as we develop our
kickoff you know that underlying
rationale was was everything for us all
right let's get more returns and we'll
get virtually 95% returns you know from
our kickoffs as opposed to the sort of
30 or 35 percent in the NFL and it's
safer and you know I don't think anybody
can argue with the underlying rationale
that's that's really the key so all
these rural innovations we've got about
a dozen or so that you know that are
where we differentiate ourselves from
the NFL it's all about the underlying
rationale and I think that's that's
where we start and that's where I think
anybody else including you know the NFL
and the competition committee would
would start so who knows what the league
will do I can't speak on behalf of the
National Football League but we
certainly like the innovations and I
think fans more or less have said hey
these are pretty good these are smart
good to talk to you Oliver and my best
to of the league and what you're doing
in say hello to Andrew fours will do
thank you thank you that's Oliver Luck
the XFL Commissioner former player and
forces father of Andrew look for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]